my passion is for Perfection and cooking
beautiful food with amazing flavors and
when it comes to Christmas you can have
stunning food that looks a million
dollars but doesn't need to cost a year
or take forever and I'm going to show
you how to do it I've been a
professional chef for over 20 years and
during this program I'll be sharing my
top Chef's Secrets showing how they can
help you make my Ultimate Christmas food
my first chef secret for Christmas is be
organized and get prepared in restaurant
kitchens we call this Nissan place
getting vegetables chopped stocks made
and sauce is ready it's the religion by
which all good chefs live
I don't want to spend Christmas in the
kitchen ignoring my family and friends
when we're all finally together so I'm
prepared with dishes that I can cook in
advance that will last over Christmas
adding a glazed ham to your holiday menu
is a great way to get ahead it's
delicious versatile and the ultimate
dish to have in the fridge for any
hungry guests who drop by
Christmas would never be the same
without a beautiful delicious honey
glazed ham across that long Christmas
period this can get you out of jail
quite easily ham salads ham sandwiches
Hamburg and chips the this is a Gammon
what you can do now is cook it so it
becomes a ham
into a pan
first things first the water
cover it completely so the whole Gammon
Cooks evenly
the important part now is adding flavor
in there
[Music]
carrots in
the leeks the more veg in there now the
more fragrant the broth becomes once the
ham is cooked that stock is
extraordinary the base to a fantastic
soup onion not finely chopped and then
homemade ham stock is packed with flavor
so it's great for making soups sauces
stews and risottos plus it can be frozen
so it's there when you need it
pan down
[Music]
peppercorns lightly Crush then to give
it a Christmas flavor I'm adding crushed
coriander seeds two cinnamon sticks and
four aromatic bay leaves up to the boil
I'm going to turn it down let it simmer
and then skim it
cooking a ham isn't hard but it does
take time this two kilo joint takes two
and a half hours to simmer before it's
glazed and baked however it is worth it
because it tastes absolutely delicious
foreign
very very simple
Demerara sugar
Madeira
that sweetens the glaze basically a
fortified wine
a couple of tablespoons
in
and then
share vinegar again couple tablespoons
honey in
nice
bring that up to the ball the longer you
leave it on the stove the darker it
becomes you want your hand really nice
and dark then cook out the glaze for
three four minutes that
I'm happy with
lovely
[Music]
right the gammon's cooked now onto the
plate
carefully snip the string
nice and gently
peel back get rid of the skin then
crisscross it don't push too deep let
the knife do the work
stud it
with some clothes
[Music]
look at it almost looks like an albino
pineapple the glaze
and just carefully
cover start in the middle and let it
work round
oh
God
gently gently gently gently
it's not even roasted yet and it looks
amazing
beautiful
look at that half the glaze over now
into the oven
15 minutes
[Music]
it started to color
look at the rest of the glaze
pour that over
look at it wow the more effort
passioned and love you show the ham now
the results are tenfold look at it every
five minutes out of the oven
and glaze again
back in the oven now
a 190 degrees we're going to baste and
roast for 35 minutes
delicious
next I'm going to make a pear and
saffron Chutney this is a fruity relish
that works brilliantly with a sweet
aromatic ham
First Things First Slice The Onion
fry the chopped onion in olive oil
without coloring it the important part
about this stage is the fact that we're
going to layer the chutney with textures
from onion to Apple to pear
and a nice little block of Ginger
grating the ginger so the ginger sort of
disappears with the onions
then add the spices a good grating of
nutmeg
followed by a teaspoon of cinnamon and a
teaspoon of canned pepper to give it a
kick delicious I recently spent a lot of
time in India where chutneys originated
and discovered that whereas British
style chutneys tend to be cooked and are
usually quite sweet Indian ones are
normally fresh spicier and quite sour
next Demerara sugar
[Music]
once that Sugar's dissolved the white
wine vinegar All In
that's going to give you this really
nice sort of sweet and sour flavor from
there our fruit
these are Williams pears
pear is the star of the Chutney so keep
it quite rustic
next add chopped cooking apples their
tanas gives a lovely contrast of the
sweetness of the pears to give it great
texture a handful of sultanas
into saffron this gives it a really nice
depth a rich golden color saffron is the
world's most expensive spice it's made
from the dried stigmas of the saffron
crocus flower and as a general rule of
thumb the deeper the color of the
threads the better the quality and to
make it lighter the zest and juice of
two oranges the orange and the saffron
go brilliantly well together just
squeeze that in there
This chutney's brilliant with ham
fantastic in sellers but equally as
delicious with fish whether it's a
roasted Cod a grilled fillet of mackerel
it goes brilliantly well bring that up
to the ball
cook that out for 15 minutes now
Tomatoes going at the end
and that brings a certain amount of
freshness to Chutney really helps to
give it that nice texture
[Music]
mix that in
I literally cook it out for 30 seconds
[Music]
what's great about this Chutney is that
as it matures its flavor gets better and
better and it will keep for up to six
months
fill up the jar
and that
is going to deliver amazing flavor
across Christmas
[Music]
and look my goodness me that
is Fit For A King
[Music]
[Music]
my new version of beef wellington
retains the luxuriousness which made it
brilliant in the first place but gives
it a seasonal lift if you want to really
spoil your friends this Christmas this
is the perfect special occasion dish
Beef Wellington has to be the ultimate
Indulgence one of my all-time favorite
main courses and it would definitely be
on my last supper menu my version is a
lot lighter and sexier and for Christmas
I'm going to give it an added twist
first off the fillet of beef now look at
it it's beautiful first the most
important part is to sear it salt pepper
the fillet is the leanest and the most
expensive cut of beef it comes from
underneath the lower backbone a part of
the animal which has very little muscle
and this is what makes it such a tender
cut very very hot pan olive oil and
literally roll it around the pan
we're not cooking the beef we're just
searing it which will really help
to give another layer of flavor and beef
in
lovely now use the side of the pan so
the beef
Sears down the back when you shilt it
it's a secret to get it done quickly it
gives that really nice roasted flavor
delicious once you've got the color very
carefully lift up the beef and see it on
top
and sear it on the bottom out and onto
the plate
English mustard
what this does now
it gives it a bit of sort of bit of heat
just lightly brush
the mustard
over the beef
so really important that you do this
as the beef comes straight out the pan
as the beef starts to cool down it
absorbs all that heat from the mustard
horseradish is a really nice alternative
as well just leave that to sit
and relax as the fillet rests prepare
the filling which is called a duck sale
put 700 grams of chestnut mushrooms into
a blender
add a chopped clove of garlic season
with salt and pepper and Blitz
Christmas wouldn't be Christmas without
chestnuts I just crumble them in
to the mushrooms the chestnuts sweet
nutty flavor works brilliantly with the
earthy Taste of the mushrooms and
because they contain more starch and
less oil than other nuts they have a
much softer texture that is perfect for
the filling
that smells amazing smells like
Christmas
once the mixture is finely chopped cook
in a hot dry pan this removes the water
from the mushrooms and intensifies the
flavor
[Music]
you can see the water coming out
instantly
such an essential stage really critical
to the success of the Wellington that
you dry those mushrooms out and get rid
of all that water take the mushrooms up
even further some fresh thyme in there
which will make it really nice and light
and fragrant
when all the water's been fried off
removed from the pan and leak to cool
then start assembling the Wellington
stage one wrapping the beef fillet first
of all
these wonderful slices of Parma ham and
look beautiful
overlap it
and set it there
so the secret of overlapping the Palmer
ham
is to make sure
contains all those juices
coming out of the beef in the
traditional recipe for beef wellington a
thick time and spring onion pancake is
used instead of ham but the Parma ham
makes the dish much lighter and it's
sweet salty flavor really complements
the mushroom and Chestnut filling
little touch of pepper no salt because
the ham is naturally salty it's a little
twist of pepper
and then from there your mushrooms
and basically
mushrooms go on
use the back of the spoon to spread them
nice and thinly half an inch from the
ends
rump holes no pop it
every time there's meat out he comes
next lay the beef on top
and very carefully
fold that over
now we're going to lift that up and wrap
the beef
nice and carefully so all that mushroom
and Palmer ham
is encasing the beef all the way over
push it nice and tight
roll it nice and tight
and go all the way over
now the secret from here
is to really let the Clinton do the work
just nip it at the ends and squeeze
and what we're doing is just creating
this wonderful sort of cylinder shape
off
and then just twist it
nice and tightly
and the tighter it is the more perfect
the shape then place in the fridge for
15 minutes to firm up
[Music]
final wrap a little bit of slim film
puff pastry
beef
now very carefully first roll the puff
pastry over the beef until the two edges
meet then trim off any excess pastry and
twist the ends together to ensure the
beef is completely sealed in its pastry
case to set that perfectly and get it
really nice and firm to make it really
cylinder type slim them over
[Music]
pull that nice and tight
but the big secret behind this is that
it can be done the night before and the
tighter the twin film the better the
shape the more even the shape
the more even it Cooks put it back in
the fridge for five minutes to firm up
again
then take off a Tim film
also the perfect Christmas cracker
to give the pastry a lovely Rich golden
brown color when it bakes brush it with
egg yolk
and then finally you don't have to do
this but it's a chefy thing a little bit
decoration the back of the Knife Down
and then just twist
and mark the pastry when it comes out
the oven
it's got that wow factor
[Music]
then a Sprinkle of salt to ensure the
pastry becomes lovely and crisp then
bake in an oven at 200 degrees for
around 35 minutes depending on how red
you like your beef once out of the oven
it's crucial you let the Wellington rest
for at least 10 minutes this allows the
meat to relax and reabsorb its delicious
juices making sure it's tender and
succulent nice and gently here that
pastry how crisp that is this is the bit
we've been waiting for
oh wow
my God
I'm in heaven and for me
if you want a really nice change to
roast turkey
this
has to be the ultimate for the table it
smells Christmassy the chestnuts the
mushrooms and that nice crisp pastry on
the outside look at it
I'm ready to die and go to heaven
[Music]
[Applause]
for a really special occasion I love to
serve my beef wellington with gloriously
creamy mashed potatoes and shavings of
Exquisite white truffle
foreign
Christmas Day morning is to tackle the
turkey and my favorite way to cook it is
roasted with lemon parsley and garlic
it's fantastically aromatic really easy
to do keeps the meat succulent and
tastes absolutely delicious
for me without question the start or the
Christmas dinner is this a delicious
turkey now once this is in the oven
you're halfway there the secret success
behind a great Christmas dinner is
making sure this doesn't turn out dry
and is all in the preparation now we're
going to make an amazing butter and this
it's sort of the start of the the most
important part keeping that bird
incredibly moist soft butter
a touch of salt and pepper
it'll touch up olive oil in there that
stops the butter from burning
next add the zest of two lemons
and their juice this gives the flavor
butter a wonderful Citrus Zing
three cloves of garlic
turkey is a very delicate dainty meat
and that's why I want the garlic pureed
so it sort of disintegrates and flavors
a turkey gently without becoming too
overpowering then add a generous handful
of chopped parsley
wow that smells incredibly light give
that a good mix
turkey's a very very very lean bird and
it dries out so so important to make
sure that we help it to cook perfectly
butter done now prepare the turkey we're
gonna season the bird inside the cavity
salt and pepper next half two onions and
pop them in as they roast they steam
inside the bird giving it a lovely
sweetness
put in the lemon and a couple of bay
leaves for their Bittersweet spicy
flavor
we're sort of lining the inside of the
turkey with these fantastic sort of
flavors you can see the bird is upright
and it's looking sort of like it's
standing to attention now it's time to
add the flavored butter just very very
carefully open up the skin go through
over the back of the breast
keep the skin intact
the idea is to gently loosen the skin
with your fingers so the butter can be
stuffed underneath it
now once you've loosened all the skin
off the top of the thighs turn the bird
around
just go through here again hand up and
just release a little bit but don't
completely break it because I don't want
all that butter to run out
right from there
now take your butter
put it into a ball
smells amazing
lemony citrusy and just sort of flatten
it and stick that in there
underneath
one side now once you've got it in there
pull back the skin and just
use that
sort of slide all the way down
what we want to do now is line the top
of the breast with all that butter there
that butter it's going to keep the
turkey breast really seriously moist
turn the bird around
I'm finished covering the breasts with
the butter
turkeys originally came from North
America and their best young and plump
my favorite breed for Christmas is
either Norfolk black or Norfolk bronze
both of which have a wonderful gamey
taste
the rest of the butter and carefully
massage over the breasts legs and wings
all this the night before and simply
cover the turkey with tinfall and keep
it in the fridge ready to be cooked on
Christmas Day
into the tray
and it will touch of olive oil now olive
oil on top again that protects it gets
that skin really nice and crispy and it
stops the butter from burning now in the
oven at 220 for 10 minutes get really
nice and brown quickly in she goes
beautiful
[Music]
that smells fantastic
after 10 minutes take the turkey out of
the oven and baste then cover the
breasts with smoked streaky bacon what I
want to do
is add a little bit more flavor I'm
already starting to think about my gravy
so the bacon protects it stops it from
drying out
but it's going to start
to really give
my gravy a wonderful base
turn down the oven to 180 degrees
this five kilogram bird will feed eight
people comfortably it needs roasting for
two and a half hours or half an hour per
kilo basting every so often
[Music]
back in and now she's on the way look at
that beautiful
as pretty as the Christmas tree that
smells fantastic
wow
look at that
beautiful that
is 90 of your work done there to test
the turkey is cooked stick a knife into
the bottom of the thigh and if the
juices run clear it's done the secret
now is to let the turkey rest uncovered
for two and a half hours as the meat
relaxes it reabsorbs its juices making
it succulent and tender plus it'll be
easier to carve it might seem like a
long time to let it rest but remember
the turkey doesn't need to be piping hot
because I'm serving it with hot gravy
that looks like a million dollars let
that rest because the flavor will be 10
times more exciting once it's rested
the key to pulling all the different
elements of your Christmas dinner
together on the plate is the gravy my
recipe for turkey gravy made with cider
and walnuts has a wonderful Appley nutty
flavor which beautifully complements the
turkey meat and fruity pork stuffing as
that turkey is resting
I want to make the most amazing gravy
and when I say amazing I really do mean
amazing
drain the excess fat from The Roasting
tray and put it back on the heat then
remove the bacon from the top of the
turkey and the roasted onions from the
cavity look at them
my God they smell amazing finally take
out the roasted lemon
first of all cut up the bacon
lovely
bacon into the tray
here how crisper that is
that's the start
of our gravy the onion look at it
beautiful it doesn't get any better than
that chop that up
onion and bacon in
that
smells incredible
when I first got the chance to cook
Christmas lunch for the chefs in Paris
they taught me one crucial thing
I was only 21 at the time but they made
me rest the turkey as long as I cooked
it
so I cooked it for three hours and I
rested it for three hours what a
difference
incredible
next chop up the roasted lemon and add
to the tray put in a couple of sprigs of
rosemary to give it a lovely aromatic
punch and Fry then add three chopped
tomatoes which helps to thicken the
gravy and give it a lovely fresh taste
[Music]
now it's time to really get the turkey
flavor into the gravy now off the wing
take off all your little trimmings all
these little bits here
add that into your gravy these are the
bits we never use
everyone throws them away
off there that little baby there
take him off
I want that
bang flavor delicious try that off
the smell is incredible
next pour in the dry cider this adds a
lovely subtle Apple flavor that really
lifts the taste of the turkey meat as
The Cider starts to reduce pour in the
delicious resting juices from the
roasted turkey wow there you go the most
amazing flavor
foreign
has reduced by half crush the vegetables
and the turkey pieces with a Masher to
extract the maximum amount of flavor
and basically what's happening now is
that we're giving the gravy a little bit
of body
pour in the chicken stock and reduce
again then
now a little taste
wow I mean just close your eyes and wow
it oozes flavor and turkey now sieve it
back of the ladle to push it through the
sieve extracting every last drop of
flavor
pop in a sprig of rosemary and leave to
infuse ready for the finishing touch
[Music]
simply add crushed walnuts to the bottom
of the gravy boat and ladle in the hot
gravy
[Music]